ta mission si tu choisis de l'
accepter Je me demande si tu as déjà choisi de ne pas
[Musique]
on craignait la fin de la guerre
et le sang sera sur tes mains les
retombées de toutes tes bonnes intentions tu as
eu un choix terrible à faire à Berlin
une vie sur des millions et maintenant le monde
est en danger c'est la mission de la CIA
s'il avait conservé le plutonium nous
n'aurions pas cette conversation
ce Tim tu serais mort oui ils le feraient
c'est le travail que tu ne comprends pas  ce dans quoi
vous êtes impliqué, vous devez vous en aller,
s'il vous plaît, ne me faites pas de codes pour vous combien
de fois les chasses les gouvernements l'ont trahi l'
ont désavoué l'ont mis de côté combien de
temps avant qu'un homme comme ça en ait
assez
même si nous sommes
alors comment est-ce  he oh tu sais même toujours
là
quand diable il fait trouve qu'il vaut mieux
ne pas accrocher